bundesregierung hat heute nachmittag die
niederlande und die ist grenzgebiet zu
frankreich als neue risikogebiete
eingestuft und da ist es für uns doch
mal einen grund in genau diese länder zu
gucken wir schauen also heute zu
verschiedenen europäischen nachbarn wir
schalten zu meinen kolleginnen anna
arendt nach paris nach frankreich mit
natalie steger werden der in warschau
reden und am ende schauen wir mal ins
vereinigte königreich zu meinem kollegen
andreas stamm wie die lage dort aussieht
fragen und kommentare zu diesem thema
vor allem jetzt auf europäischer ebene
sprich was machen andere europäische
länder anders als wir wie ist die lage
dort warum ist das infektionsgeschehen
dort zum beispiel so hoch was machen die
anders gerne in die dafür vorgesehenen
kommentarspalten oder an diese e mail
adresse hier unten zdf heute.de zdf.de
und wir fangen jetzt gleich schon mal an
und schalten nach paris zu meiner
kollegin hannah arendt du stehst dann
mit maske anne ist das bei euch jetzt
der alltag in paris dass man nur noch
mit so einem guten pulli wie man in
hamburg sagt im gesicht auf die straße
darf ja die maske ist ja wirklich ein
gegenwärtig ist schlicht überall auf der
straße in den büros in der metro man man
sieht sie wirklich überall und sie steht
auch dafür dass das virus so
allgegenwärtig ist aber die maske allein
scheint ja nicht zu reichen
die zahlen steigen es gibt eigentlich
kaum mehr ein fleck auf der karte von
frankreich der nicht gut eingezeichnet
ist rot für die warnung achtung die
krankenhäuser laufen voll
achtung wir müssen handeln sonst kriegen
wir das ganze nicht mehr in den griff
und das war auch so ein bisschen der
tenor und gestern von dem von der rede
macros der wirklich alle bürger
appelliert hat jetzt müssen wir uns alle
zusammenreißen und uns an die regeln
halten sonst verlieren wir die kontrolle
das heißt was war das für eine stimmung
die präsident ma konter in diesem
fernsehinterview verbreitet hat hier in
deutschland war ja doch die bundes
darin sehr sehr besorgt hat auch von
unheil gesprochen was soll s nicht
verhindert werden kann man das auch so
der tenor beim akt aber so ein bisschen
verhalten habe er sagte auf die lage sei
besorgniserregend und er sagte auch die
ressourcen werden langsam knapp und die
ressourcen werden langsam knapp damit
weiter her vor allen dingen die
krankenhäuser also da wird ganz genau
geschaut wie es sieht das auf den
intensivstationen aus in den großen
städten laufen da die stationen voll in
paris zum beispiel sind jetzt 46 prozent
der intensivbetten mit komapatienten
gelegt und das personal ist wirklich am
anschlag
wir schauen uns mal ein bisschen so die
gesamtlage entspannt vielleicht an seine
kollegin christel haas hatte ein kleines
stück für uns gemacht
spätabends noch schnell einen wein ab
samstag wird das in den französischen
corona hotspots nicht mehr möglich sein
dann gilt eine ausgangssperre von 21 bis
6 uhr morgens wir müssen handeln
erklärte gestern präsident makro im
fernsehinterview
wir müssen die privaten kontakte
reduzieren denn das sind die
gefährlichsten
also ja die ausgangssperre ist
angemessen gemünzt ist das auf die
jüngeren die trotz corona oft ohne maske
und abstand feiern
doch es trifft vor allem gastronomen und
kulturschaffende ja es werde insolvenzen
geben sagt der präsident verspricht aber
finanzielle unterstützung
frankreich erlebt eine starke zweite
corona welle die krankenhäuser schlagen
erlagen im großraum paris sind über 40
prozent der intensivbetten belegt makro
versucht sich an der quadratur des
kreises die pandemie einzudämmen ohne
gleichzeitig die wirtschaft ganz
abzuwürgen
er fordert dafür den rückhalt aller
franzosen wir kommen da nicht raus wenn
nicht jeder einzelne verantwortung
übernimmt
der präsident zeigt dennoch zuversicht
und übernimmt am ende den berühmten satz
der bundeskanzlerin
wir schaffen das niveau
da sind die beiden sich mal eigentlich
an du hast gerade schon angesprochen
dass die zahlen in frankreich bei euch
ziemlich hoch sind die gucken wir uns
mal ganz konkret kurz an
wir haben da mal was vorbereitet
die grafik ist gut so
da da können wir sehen in frankreich
haben wir 66,9 millionen einwohner und
gestern gab es 22 1591 neuinfektionen
insgesamt gibt es 33 1037 tote und wir
haben eine fallzahl von 779 1063 das
sind ziemlich drastische zahlen und
darüber spreche ich mit meiner kollegin
hannah arendt um paris welche maßnahmen
gibt es denn jetzt konkret bei euch also
maske hast du grad schon erzählt die
muss man überall tragen wenn man sich
quasi nicht in seinen eigenen vier
wänden bewegt was gibt es denn noch so
tatsächlich wird auch zu der maske in
den eigenen vier wänden geraten nämlich
wenn man besuch empfängt micro hat
gestern allen geraten wenn sie sicher
ist sozusagen die freunde einladen da
niemals mehr als sechs personen an einem
tisch das ist die eine maßnahme oder na
ja keine maßnahme eher eine empfehlung
wirklich drastische maßnahmen sind ist
die ausgangssperre die gilt in paris und
den acht weiteren großen städten und
zwar von 21 uhr am abend bis um 6 uhr
morgens das heißt man darf wirklich nur
in ausnahmefällen das haus verlassen und
besonders hart trifft es natürlich die
gastronomen also für die bedeutet das
sie können ein essen am abend servieren
und dann müssen sie eigentlich schon
ihre gäste verabschieden nämlich die
müssen ja irgendwie
rechtzeitig zu hause sein arm 21 uhr
muss die straße dann mehr sein
ist das etwas was die franzosen
tatsächlich so annehmen ich meine unser
klischee hier gerade formen leben in
paris ist man ist viel draußen mann ist
in cafés mann ist in bars man trifft
sich viel mit freunden genießt das gute
leben
das ist ja unser vorteil gegenüber den
franzosen passt das tatsächlich zu dem
geschehen gerade also man kann
vielleicht einmal schauen was eigentlich
nach dieser ersten infektionswelle im
frühjahr passiert ist danach als
sozusagen der lockdown vorbei war hat
sich das leben in paris oder in
frankreich eigentlich wieder ganz normal
angefühlt also die bars und restaurants
waren voll in den großen städten ebenso
wie an den küsten die man das immerfort
frankreich kennt und viele franzosen
haben ja auch aufgrund der
reisebeschränkungen im eigenen land
urlaub gemacht in marseille die
bürgermeisterin hat neulich gestanden
ich glaube wir haben diesen sommer die
eine oder andere terrassen party zu viel
gefeiert und ob man sich jetzt an diese
beschränkungen hält ist wird sich ja ab
dem wochenende zeigen denn man gelten
die ja erst was man gesagt hat ist das
ganze wird streng kontrolliert 12.000
polizisten sollen dafür eingesetzt
werden
und wer nach 21 uhr draußen auf der
straße erwischt wird zeigt 135 euro es
gibt hier eine frage in den kommentaren
ich habe sie gerade gesehen ich muss mal
zurück
scrollen die gehen ähnlich kommen gerade
nicht mehr finden von wem sie war sie
gegen die richtung ob es in frankreich
auch so viele menschen gibt die quasi
bezweifeln dass corona tatsächlich eine
tödliche pandemie ist oder eine
gefährliche pandemie und an den
maßnahmen generell große fragezeichen
engel ist das bei euch auch so
naja an den maßnahmen große fragezeichen
lenken kann ich jetzt nicht so
beobachten was ich tatsächlich im alltag
beobachten ist dass das mit den
abstandsregeln so eine sache ist also
zum beispiel in der metro oder auf den
rolltreppen dann sind rolltreppe
gefahren dicht an dicht obwohl die man
die treppe ist oder man könnte
eigentlich laufen ein bisschen abstand
halten
ich denke maske wird brav getragen ja
aber abstand halten also sowohl so im
öffentlichen raum als auch in den bars
und cafés da stehen die tische nach wie
vor in dicht an dicht
das kann ich jetzt nicht so beobachten
aber woran liegt denn das dann dass die
franzosen oder das ist so hohe
fallzahlen bei euch gebe ich meine maske
wird bei uns ja auch empfohlene aha
regeln haben wir hier abstand denn war
schon abstand alltags maske aufziehen
das heißt wenn die wir euch die ganze
zeit getragen wird dann würde ich jetzt
als laie erwarten dass die zahlen
eigentlich unter kontrolle sind wo ist
das problem
der abstand also würde ich das
beurteilen kann nicht sagen
die zahlen steigen
weil dieses oder jenes nicht befolgt man
muss auch einfach mal sehen
bei der ersten infektionswelle damals
wurde ja gar nicht so vermessen wie
jetzt gemessen das sind ja mehr als eine
million testen gibt mittlerweile in der
woche gemacht werden das kann man im
grunde nicht so 1&1 gegenüberstellen
dies sind das mit dem gesundheitssystem
in frankreich die deutschen rühmen sich
ja immer dass sie so ein tolles
gesundheitssystem haben mit vielen
intensivbetten vielen gesundheitsämtern
die viel kontrollieren und die konnte
infektionsketten nachverfolgen ist es in
frankreich
[Musik]
also es ist so nach dieser ersten
infektionswelle das hatte ich ja eben
beschrieben hatte man so ein bisschen
das gefühl jetzt kommt die freiheit
wieder zurück und jetzt im herbst kommt
eben der schock damals nach der ersten
infektionswelle wurden tausende an
krankenhausbetten versprochen es wurde
mehr personal versprochen es wurde
bessere bezahlung versprochen und jetzt
heißt es plötzlich acht wir kriegen das
doch nicht so schnell geben und ich hab
so ein bisschen den eindruck man hat das
einfach so ein bisschen wenig
verschlafen aber man hat diese zeit in
der es weniger ansteckungen nicht
genutzt und jetzt kommt eben der schock
hier ist eine frage von dan f auf
youtube gab es von deutschland schon
hilfsangebote an die französischen
nachbarn oder andersrum frage ich jetzt
mal gab es doch auch schon hilfsgesuche
das vielleicht weil er hier intensiv
betten leer stehen dass franzosen in
deutsche krankenhäuser geflogen werden
oder gefahren werden nein also an dem
punkt sind wir noch nicht das gab es ja
tatsächlich im frühjahr da wurden
patienten zum beispiel aufs netz nach
nordrhein westfalen in eine klinik
geflogen
aber ich meine so weit ist dass hier
noch nicht also circa 40 prozent der
intensivbetten mit sind mit vormonat
zugelegt das ist
noch nicht so dass die schließen das
sind die intensivstation aber ist schon
eine ganze menge
hier ist eine frage ganz persönlich an
dich von david trone auf facebook kannst
du als journalistin noch normal
weiterarbeiten und gelten die ausgangs
beschränkungen auch für dich also
momentan können wir noch normal unter
anführungszeichen weiterarbeiten für uns
im täglichen geschäft bedeutet es
natürlich dass wir auch unter den
kollegen abstand halten
da wo es möglich ist also muss
einzelbüros gibt können wir ins büro
gehen ansonsten lüften wir ganz viel wir
fahren in getrennten fahrzeugen
wir tragen maske auf den flur in der
küche und so weiter konferenzen werden
nur noch online abgehalten
und ja ich darf morgens zur arbeit
fahren und auch abends wieder zurück
denn für alle die die arbeiten gibt es
ausnahmegenehmigungen weil es gibt ja
auch krankenschwestern die in der nacht
im krankenhaus müssen
schichtarbeiter und so weiter also zur
arbeit darf man auch zwischen 21 uhr
abends und 6 uhr morgens fahren
an vielen dank für diese eindrücke aus
paris nach frankreich und neben dir das
konzert sehen ist schon unsere kollegin
natalie zu sehen natalie steger in
warschau da gebe ich die frage gleich
mal an dich weiter natalie wie ist das
denn bei euch in polen kannst du auch
ganz normal arbeiten
oder gibt es da auch bei dir jetzt schon
beschränkungen dass du zum beispiel
getrennte autos benutzen muss man nutzen
um drews also normal ist hier seit mehr
als nichts mehr und das ging bei uns
sehr früh los weil die folie auch sehr
früh die grenzen dicht gemacht haben
sehr viel masten pflicht verordnet haben
wir konnten am anfang auch kaum vox pop
als interviews auf der straße machen die
leute waren da sehr ängstlich wir
arbeiten im büro ähnlich wie eine das
gerade geschildert hat bei uns gibt es
gar keine zweier büros mehr wir sind
alle getrennt wir hatten am anfang und
den kata wirklich zu hause sitzen drei
monate lang
das könnte auch wieder so kommen weil
unsere zahlen ja auch echt schlecht
zinßer zeit und immer schlechter werden
und der kata der als meine beiträge
schneide und ich wir sitzen nicht in
einem raum wir haben wir so technisches
zeug geregelt er natürlich nicht ich er
sitzt oben ich sitz unten wir haben
sogar toiletten getrennt die
verwaltungsdaten ist im haben erstes
also wir sind komplett vereinzelt und
fahren bis auch das haben wir auch im
sommer gemacht als alles wieder besser
aber da sind wird im großen bus wieder
aufträge fallen wir fahren wenn wir
fahren nur die notwendigen dienstreisen
und die dann tatsächlich mit zwei autos
ihren jetzt kommt hier ein kommentar auf
facebook von dieter vaas künstlern zeigt
doch mal filmaufnahmen von draußen das
werden wir jetzt tun wir haben hier
folgenden bericht für euch es ist punkt
10 am morgen und seit heute dürfen
zwischen 10 und 12 uhr exklusiv nur
senioren über 60 jahre alt zum einkaufen
gehen das gab es im frühjahr schon
einmal ich bin zufrieden
manchmal sehe ich hier lange schlangen
ich meide sie also ich finde das ist
eine absolut gute idee die
zurückgekommen ist
sie haben ein privileg aber gleichzeitig
macht genau das ihnen auch sorgen denn
polen muss die korona maßnahmen
verschärfen weil die zahlen nahezu
täglich steigen
am anfang der pandemie haben die
krankenhäuser die krise noch gut
gemeistert doch experten fürchten jetzt
nichts gutes wir haben wirklich eine
ernste gefährliche situation im
gesundheitswesen nahezu acht busse mit
patienten treffen täglich in den
krankenhäusern ein
bald wird es für sie keinen platz geben
wo sie versorgt werden können
die polizei informiert mit lautsprechern
es herrscht masken pflicht auch im
freien ein fahrradfahrer wird ohne
erwischt die polizei kann in diesen
fällen bis zu umgerechnet 110 euro
aufbrummen polen im kampf gegen korona
ja also da ist wirklich was los bei euch
in polen nachdem die steeger unserer
korrespondentin in warschau ist nicht
zugeschaltet ist das immer noch so dass
die stimmung dort so ist dass die
menschen tatsächlich sorge haben sich
untereinander zu begegnen kannst du
jetzt wieder auf die straße gehen und
interviews machen wir da ist es wie im
frühjahr nee das geht auch mit mit mit
lange dass man eben das mikro ziemlich
weit weg
das geht es ist ein bisschen entspannter
geworden aber die leute haben noch große
sorgen ich würde sagen die polen waren
im vergleich zu deutschland ich war
natürlich in der zeit hier aber ich
hatte so den eindruck hatten sie sehr
früh sehr große sorgen auch bei mir im
büro oder wurde sie darauf gedrängt dass
wir uns vereinzeln die polen haben dass
wir uns viel viel ernster genommen am
große sorge schützen ihre alten wir
haben es gerade gesehen sehr gut und
haben auch wirklich sie sind sehr
wichtig die älteren herrschaften zu
sicherheit zu schützen
man hat viele hilfsangebote essens
auslieferung für senioren angefangen
also dieses dieses corona virus damit
leben die leute hier irgendwie es gibt
eigentlich keine illegalen partys
weniger es gab jetzt ein paar
infektionsherde auch bei hochzeiten und
ähnliches das fällt aber demnächst jetzt
auch aus ab samstag in großen teilen
polens diese hochzeiten also die polen
haben das sehr schön sehr ernst genommen
und wenn man zum beispiel auch gesehen
hat wie das fernsehen berichtet hat in
polen
da gibt es seit märz keine studiogäste
mehr es gibt das nicht dass die leute
getrennt sitzen mit wänden oder sowas
die werden alle zugeschaltet wie
erklärst du dass das die polen das virus
so ernst nehmen und andere europäische
nachbarn jetzt nicht so du kannst das
nicht für frankreich sprechen aber gibt
es da grund den du herausgefunden hat
das die polen das dann doch sehr
restriktiv durchziehen
vielleicht haben die polen sich dann
einfach daran gewöhnen dass sie diesen
regeln folgen aber ich glaube dass es
sehr spekulatives ist einfach auch
wirklich die sorge um die gesundheit die
sehr groß ist und vielleicht wird auch
nicht so hinterfragt wie ich das aus
deutschland höher gibt es das virus
überhaupt und so weiter es gab jetzt am
wochenende mal ein paar demos die
natürlich auch kleiner ausgefallen sind
wegen der restriktionen aber sind
wirklich es gibt diese corona zweifel
gibt es praktisch nicht
ich glaube da glaubt man ein stück weit
mehr den behörden wenn man auch
natürlich
nicht alles glaubt dass diese regierung
macht wir schauen mal kurz auf die
zahlen in polen da haben wir auch eine
grafik vorbereitet polen bewegt sich da
im europäischen vergleich im mittelfeld
mit 37 19 millionen einwohnern gibt es
dort 8099 neuinfektionen seit gestern
und 3308 tote mit oder an kowitz seit
dem beginn der pandemie und insgesamt
gibt es in polen 149000 103 fälle das
ist wie gesagt ein mittelwert ich würde
sehr gerne eigentlich das dashboard
zeigen vom european center of disease
control leider ist diese webseite echt
schwierig und stürzt mir ständig up von
daher können wir da nicht drauf schalten
aber kann jeder mal selber ein geben
vielleicht funktioniert bei euch hat zu
hause besser ich habe nachgesehen polen
ist wirklich so im mittelfeld aber immer
noch mit 150 erkrankten auf 100000 den
letzten 14 tagen doch schon eine
besorgniserregende zahl natalie welche
maßnahmen gibt es jetzt konkret bei euch
im land also wir haben ja gesehen
frankreich masken tragen überall haben
wir auch ein beitrag zu sehen was geht
es denn noch masken tragen ist bei uns
auch überall auch draußen überall
zurzeit ist es noch relativ locker
gewesen mit den beschränkungen aber es
gibt jetzt am samstag immer mehr
sogenannte rote zonen also ganz
besonders viele fälle sind dort darf
tatsächlich was ich gesagt hatte keine
hochzeit mehr gefeiert werden
restaurants müssen um 21 uhr zu machen
danach gibt's nur take away die
schwimmbäder sind zu die fitness ist zu
das wurde alles heute abend von mooren
jetzt geht vom polnischen
ministerpräsidenten verkündet die
gottesdienste ist auch wichtig für die
katholischen polen wäre da werden auch
die besucherzahlen werden eingeschränkt
und bei den schulen da ist man so ein
bisschen hin und her gerissen gewesen
weil man auf der einen seite
sie sagte die kinder brauchen natürlich
die sozialen kontakte die kinder weil
wir sehr lange im homeschooling auch
früher als in deutschland im frühjahr
jetzt hat man sich doch entschieden dass
man die universitäten doch wieder online
hat und die kinder etwa ab der neunten
klasse wieder online packt während die
kleineren wir dürfen noch nun die ganz
kleinen die dürfen sogar ohne maske in
die schule gehen gibt es einen kommentar
von bickel auf facebook die polen kennen
noch die wertschätzung den alten
gegenüber mit drei klatschenden händen
nichtsdestotrotz sind die zahlen noch
relativ hoch also mittelfeld habe ich
schon gesagt im europäischen vergleich
worin liegt das gibts da irgendwie
erkenntnisse also dass bei uns die
zahlen jetzt meinst du die nahezu
täglichen rekord haben das vor allem
daran dass jetzt sehr viel getestet wird
das war am anfang nicht so daran die
test kapazitäten nicht so hoch es liegt
schlicht und ergreifend daran dass jetzt
60 70.000 tests gemacht wurden mitunter
man 120 1000 das ist eigentlich der
erklärung warum die zahlen so hochgehen
und natürlich dass es auch eigentlich
für das was wir gerade aus frankreich
gehört haben naja das mit den kontakt
und die ein meter fünfzig oder die zwei
meter oder die vier quadratmeter
die man im restaurant dafür eine person
einrechnet da habe ich den eindruck das
ist nicht mehr ganz so genau und ordner
ich glaube dass der sommer dran schuld
als es war wirklich ausgesprochen extrem
wie die distanz eingehandelt eingehalten
wurde im frühling da kam der sommer der
locker und wurde gelockert es ging an
die ostsee die ein meter fünfzig waren
vergessen die maske irgendwie am kinn
oder unter den
und jetzt ist das wieder disziplinierter
mit den masken da wird man auch sehr
darauf hingewiesen wenn man einkauft zum
beispiel darf man auch nicht rein in die
geschäfte zumal man sich jetzt auch
draußen tragen muss seit einer weile
aber ich glaube schon oder ich merke
schon dass in den geschäften das also
dass ihr habt schon viel geringer
geworden ist die leute drängen sich dann
doch mal an einem vorbei geht es warten
kritischen kommentaren unsere richtung
ins gegen gegen zdf von bettina müller
auf facebook warum wir wieder panik
verbreiten würden oder sollten die
deutschen glauben dass es hier noch ganz
relaxed gehandhabt wird
also liebe frau müller wir wollen hier
wirklich keine panik verbreiten wir
wollen aufklären wir wollen schauen wie
es bei den europäischen nachbarn
aussieht bei denen ist ja durchaus von
den zahlen her sehr viel heftiger zugeht
als bei uns hier in deutschland und wir
fanden es einfach interessant diesen
europäischen vergleich zu sehen zu
gucken wie sich die unterschiedlichen
nachbarn da verhalten das ist der grund
für diesen live stream
natalie ich habe hier eine frage noch
mal von david in richtung politik
profitiert die pis partei die ja auch
relativ konservativ und restriktiv
unterwegs ist von corona oder versucht
die regierung die lage für sich zu
nutzen
ich denke dass die regierung am anfang
sehr stark profitierte von corona weil
man sehr früh sehr streng gehandelt hat
und die polen das akzeptiert haben
ich denke hier schlichter jetzt die
zahlen werden und wenn hätte man die
beatmungsgeräte knapp werden wollen dann
profitiert man da überhaupt nicht mehr
es gibt im pool etwa 1000
beatmungsgeräte laut
gesundheitsministerium sind 508 belegt
und wenn die zahlen weiter so hochgehen
der mathematiker von der uni warschau
das errechnet dann sind die
beatmungsgeräte in zwei wochen besetzt
und dann wird es wahrscheinlich wirklich
problematisch es ist auch so dass es
zwischen den apps nun der politik der
regierung einigermaßen streit gibt daher
zum beispiel häufig zitierter erstmal
ein minister gesagt sein
demnach sei eines der probleme aktuell
zu wenig engagement der erste in corona
zeiten und ein hochrangiger politiker
also von der regierungspartei hat gesagt
viel erste würden es vermeiden das
gesundheitssystem zu unterstützen
ich bin mir nicht sicher ob dieses ärzte
bashung so gut ankommt da gab es in den
sozialen netzwerken einen großen
aufschrei ärzte posten zum beispiel
bilder von sich fotos von sich nach
ihren schichten also da bin ich mir
nicht so sicher ob das wirklich der pis
jetzt in die hände spielt die regierung
hat sich jetzt oder denn immer jetzt hat
sich heute explizit bei den ärzten
bedankt weil ich glaube dass der ein
streit mit den ärzten denen auch hier
applaudiert wurde im frühling von den
balkons wir überall dass ein streit
jetzt nicht besonders klug wäre von der
pis so jetzt gibt's dennoch lob von uns
für uns von ursula wiedmann danke für
die informative sendungen
das nehme ich gerne an gibt es an die
kollegen weiter natalie vielen dank für
die eindrücke aus polen
und wir schalten dann gleich mal weiter
über den ärmelkanal zu meinem kollegen
andreas stamm andreas wir gerade gehört
in polen gibt es etwas unwillen oder
unruhe bei den ärzten das habe ich aus
dem vereinigten königreich am anfang der
partie auch mitbekommen eine meiner
freundinnen ist dort auch im nfs
unterwegs ist als ärztin im krankenhaus
die wir sehr empört wie es denn jetzt
gerade die stimmung beim medizinischen
personal bei euch in im vereinigten
königreich
die bereiten sich auf denn man muss es
so sagen ein schlag der zweiten welle
vor auch wenn das vielleicht ein
bisschen boulevard das klingt aber genau
das ist ist also es gibt hier die
berichte aus den krankenhäusern
die wirklich in der ersten welle da märz
april mai bis in den juni hinein einem
anschlag gearbeitet haben und und das
irgendwie über die runden gebracht haben
mit der höchsten zahl an toten in europa
das darf man nicht vergessen im
vereinigten königreich und die jetzt
natürlich wissen es kommt wieder denn
die mediziner und die virologen sind
sich eigentlich einig um diese zweite
welle einzudämmen ist es zu spät das
virus ist außer kontrolle wieder und
jetzt gehts im endeffekt da weiter oder
da wieder los wo man im märz stand das
hat auch
der oberste mediziner englands der
ärztliche direktor des managers des
staatlichen gesundheitsdienst erklärt
der sagte wir haben wieder so viele
patienten und sogar noch mehr patienten
mit corona in den krankenhäusern wie im
märz als wir damals in den nationalen
lockdown gegangen sind und wenn wir
jetzt nicht handeln dann wird die zahl
der toten unerträglich genauso hat er
gesprochen und ich glaube das ist die
stimmung unter den ärzten den schwestern
pflegern ärztinnen und wer da alles im
krankenhaus dabei ist denn das sind
natürlich die dies am ehesten spüren und
dies am deutlichsten abbekommen das sind
alles nicht so gute aussichten du hast
uns auch ein stück über die stimmung in
großbritannien gemacht das gucken uns
erst mal zusammen hat es geht wieder los
wie damals im märz die intensivstation
des wüsten hospitals nahe liverpool
fühlt sich mit corona patienten fast
alle betten belegt die region gehört zu
englands virus hotspots wir haben die
eindrücke aus der ersten welle tief in
uns vergraben weil es so stressig war
und nun kommt die zweite welle und das
gefühl der angst kommt bei allen zurück
ein crooner déjà vu auch in der politik
am montag stellt premier johnson ein
drei stufen bekämpfung system vor je
nach regionalen fallzahlen greifen
maßnahmen von der gastronomie
sperrstunde über das verbot privater
treffen bis zum punkt an dem papst bars
oder friseure wieder schließen müssen
wir könnten auch gleich in einen
nationalen locker umgehen viele menschen
halten das für extrem und es würde
unserer wirtschaft einen weiteren
enormen schaden zufügen in sachen corona
beruft sich johnston immer auch
wissenschaftliche erkenntnisse doch ein
geliebtes dokument zeigt schon mitte
september waren das wissenschaftliche
beratergremium der regierung ein
schneller radikaler landesweiter
lockdown müsse her sonst verliere man
wieder die kontrolle über das virus und
schade der wirtschaft deutlich mehr
da stellt sich die frage andrea stamm in
london ob boris johnson dann nichts
gelernt hat hat er seine haltung
gegenüber dieser pandemie gar nicht
geändert ist er war ja immerhin im
krankenhaus selber mit kuwait 19
pro johnson war selbst erkrankt er war
auf der intensivstation er wurde beatmet
und es gab damals vorbereitungen es
wurden vorbereitungen getroffen für sein
ableben also das war kein spaß er hat
das auch selbst danach in interviews
deutlich gemacht aber er ist in einer
politisch sehr vertrackten situationen
und das ist ganz schwer für ihn denn er
hat seine eigene parteien der viele
viele sagen wir haben nicht nur die
höchste zahl der toten in europa gehabt
sondern auch den krassesten
wirtschaftsabsturz hingelegt in dieser
ersten welle
wir können es uns nicht mehr leisten in
einem weiteren lockdown zugehen harte
maßnahmen schließen von geschäften von
restaurants von papst von bars und auf
der anderen seite hat er dann die die
sagen aber wenn wir das nicht tun wird
die zahl der toten steigen mit die zahl
der fälle steigen ist werden wieder die
krankenhäuser die werden überlastet sein
und es wird der wirtschaft dann wieder
mehr schaden weil langfristig gesehen
natürlich dann wieder ein locker und
irgendwann notwendig ist wenn man es
eben nicht mehr ertragen kann und dann
dauert der wieder viel länger wie beim
ersten mal und schadet der wirtschaft
wieder viel länger das ist alles
natürlich immer sehr abhängig von der
situation in der man sich befindet aber
wie groß die rebellion ist nicht nur den
eigenen reihen das hat sich heute
gezeigt denn man möchte gerne die
regierung möchte greater manchester also
die metropolregion um manchester in
diese stufe 3 bringen das dann müssen
bars pubs wieder schließen friseure
fitnessstudios und da regt sich
widerstand der bürgermeister gesagt wir
machen das nicht
wir werden das nicht tun wir werden euch
nicht mehr folgen das ist zwar ein
labour mann also opposition
aber man sieht die briten sind extrem
virulent die engländer im norden das ist
auch ein alter konflikt nord süd und man
muss sagen da kommt er schwer raus wir
gucken auch mal hier auf die zahlen die
es gerade aus den vereinigten königreich
gibt da haben wir was vorbereitet da ist
die grafik dort gibt es insgesamt 66,6 5
millionen einwohner 19 1724
neuinfektionen seit gestern dann 43.200
45 tote bislang mit oder an group mit 19
verstorben insgesamt 654 1644 fälle das
sind schon gewaltige zahlen andreas
kramer in london woran liegt denn das
also die zahlen in der ersten welle man
hat es total verschlafen die regierung
war völlig überfordert am anfang mit der
reaktion und man hat unentschlossen und
falsch gehandelt und hat sich damit
diese erste welle
extrem heftig einfach eingefahren und
man muss sagen was nicht hilft ist dass
viele in großbritannien doch eine ich
sag's mal ganz bewusst eine es oft
mentalität haben gegenüber
einschränkenden maßnahmen also ich lauf
hier über die die flaniermeile meines
stadtviertels und da sind die backups
und die bars und die restaurants und da
hat in den letzten wochen sich wirklich
niemand um abstand geschert es hat auch
überhaupt kein interessiert wenn man
irgendwo essen geht wird nicht
aufgeschrieben werden also es
funktioniert überhaupt nicht masken im
supermarkt die hälfte trägt keine maske
auch immer noch nicht also da ist
einfach unglaublich viel unwillen die
regeln zu befolgen oder auch unwissen
oder vielleicht einfach bock losigkeit
das ist schwer zu beurteilen
deshalb haben wir das mal
deutschlandvergleich durch meinen
sommerurlaub nicht genug anscheinend
also natürlich beeindruckt dass viele
ich meine es ein großes land und umso
älter man wird umso vorsichtiger mann
wird um so viele viele faktoren familien
hat oder sich mit mit oma und opa
treffen will vielleicht wird man dann
vorsichtiger aber viele geben eben da
nicht viel drauf und das merkt man im
straßenbild wie gesagt ich war im sommer
in deutschland und war überrascht im
urlaub und dachte man im supermarkt
jeder maske über alles warten ein ganz
anderes straßenbild natürlich war das
der korona sommer der freiheiten aber
das hat sich hier bis jetzt kaum
verändert hier gibt's eine frage noch
mal von david kohlen auf facebook das
heute wirklich gut unterwegs mit guten
fragen muss ich sagen er möchte wissen
ob corona die inländischen probleme
überdeckt wie zum beispiel die
unabhängigkeitsbestrebungen schottland
oder irland konflikte oder ich würde
noch ergänzen den exit überdecken wäre
schön ganz das gegenteil ist der fall so
die zahlen für die schottische
unabhängigkeit sind so hoch wie nie also
die befürworter das hat noch nie gegeben
fast 60 prozent sind man diese umfragen
natürlich immer schwierig und ein
entscheidender faktor neben dem rexit
ist das handling von
durch die zentralregierung hier in
london auch andere probleme wieder
praxis werden völlig überlagert denn die
wirtschaft läuft amok wir haben ja bald
braig sieht übergangsphase ende dann
muss es einen neuen vertrag geben das
wird ein ganz harter bruch aber gibt es
keinen vertrag wird der so hart dass
viele in der wirtschaft sagen das können
wir nicht vertragen wir haben schon
durch corona unglaublichen schaden
erlitten ein dragset ohne handelsvertrag
das geht nicht und ob also in allen
politikbereichen ist corona das was ist
verschlimmert auseinandertreibt
dividiert und man muss auch eines sagen
die briten stellen zum ersten mal fest
was föderalismus bedeutet denn das gibt
es hier eigentlich erst seit 20 25
jahren dass man die landesteile england
schottland wales und nordirland ein
bisschen abgetrennt hat und das
funktioniert überhaupt nicht die sind
autonom in gesundheitsfragen haben auch
teilweise andere regelungen aber die
absprache die koordination muss es so
sagen ist nah an einer katastrophe
andreas vielen dank ich vermute wir
werden dann in den nächsten monaten noch
öfter miteinander sprechen hier im
livestream für heute aber erstmal danke
für die eindrücke aus großbritannien
und ich würde jetzt abschließend noch
mal gerne über ein paar kommentare gehen
die ich hier bekommen habe zum beispiel
von gitarrist ins ich höre die botschaft
schreibt er allein der glaube fehlt mir
das ist mein problem ich sehe keine
leichenwagen der nachbarschaft oder in
der stadt herumfahren
die beerdigungsinstitut um auch in
kurzarbeit keiner mehr zum arzt geht das
ist mein problem hier werden verladen
nach teufel komm raus
lieber heraus ganz ich würde jetzt
vermuten was jemand antworten würde der
politik ist oder auch sich mit diesem
virus auskennt das ist ja quasi genau
das bestreben gewesen dass dieses dass
diese virenlast eben nicht überhandnimmt
dass es nicht zu diesen szenen kommt
wenn wir aber in die europäischen
nachbarländer gucken was wir gerade
gemacht haben stellen wir fest dass dort
die zahlen steigen und dass auch die
sterblichkeit dort wieder steigt die im
sommer heruntergegangen ist so deswegen
hoffen wir dass sie einfach mit diesem
stream gerade so ein bisschen aufklären
konnten es gibt aber auch da wieder
verschiedene meinungen zb einmal nach
spanien spanien ist ja doch auch relativ
in der spitze da haben wir einmal frau
müller ich hoffe ich finde sie die hat
nämlich gerade auch noch mal kommentiert
genau und sagte sie lebt in spanien und
in deutschland hat die familie und
deswegen sieht sie beide länder täglich
seit monaten im vergleich ist es absolut
lächerlich dass das neue risikogebiete
von deutsch
erklärt werden ich weiß es nicht ganz
genau was sie meinen frau müller die
risikogebiete im europäischen ausland
oder die in deutschland wenn man das
natürlich vergleich sind die zahlen in
deutschland immer noch relativ gering
aber das bestreben der regierung scheint
ja zu sein dass eben nichts außer
kontrolle geraten zu lassen wie das in
manchen europäischen nachbarländern der
fall ist und da gibt es eine
gegenmeinung zu nämlich auf facebook
davon rosemarie jung das ist die nada
weg mehr da ist deutschland geht s
spitze im vergleich zu spanien schreibt
die ich lebe in spanien seit 18 jahren
und man ja hier würde sofort mit den
deutschen tauschen und das kann ich
tatsächlich auch aus meiner eigenen
erfahrung bestätigen
wir haben ein spanisches ob er seit ein
paar tagen und die ist ehrlich gesagt
ziemlich froh dass sie in deutschland
ist so ich schaue mal ob es noch andere
kommentare gibt hier von hannah ladebeck
auf facebook jetzt noch ein als schwedin
kann nicht das gemeckere hier in
deutschland nicht nachvollziehen
deutschland hat bisher die weltweite
krise gut gemeistert und ich hoffe dass
deutschland jetzt gut durch die zweite
welle kommt so das glaube ich hoffen wir
alle bei jeder kritik die natürlich
immer berechtigt ist auch an den
massnahmen chaos was teilweise hier in
deutschland herrscht da werden wir
weiter darüber berichten natürlich aber
für heute seien jetzt erst mal vielen
dank für die aufmerksamkeit
bis zum nächsten mal und tschüss